a former Croatian general really awful
guy who was convicted of war crimes
swallowed poison right in the middle of
his trial at The Hague this happened
yeah that's right this guy just
swallowed a big thing of poison he chose
to kill himself rather than face his
prison sentence I guess that was his way
of getting out of it yeah that it was
just such a weird thing to see yeah
that's not so weird okay that's that's
Tony one of our cameramen at Tony what
are you talking about oh come on we've
all taken poison to get out of things
right no Tony we all haven't taken
poison to get out of things the key is
to just kill yourself just a little bit
what the hell are you talking about how
do you kill yourself just a little bit
well you got to have the right poison
and my choice is Mendelson cyanide sips
a perfectly measured amount of poison to
kill you for just a tad just a tad yeah
I poison myself all the time to get out
of stuff take a look Tony what do you
think of this shirt
Oh Tony hey Tony my daughter selling
girl-scout cookies oh I don't think what
the girls come home we're gonna watch
la-la land
la-la land sounds great oh excuse me you
have five minutes to talk about net
neutrality net neutrality sure sir Tony
it
you really poison yourself a lot yeah
I've been dead 172 times that's that's
incredible tell us what is the afterlife
like huh it's like a really cool water
park okay Tony this is fascinating why
don't you come over to my place tonight
just the two of us we'll have dinner
we'll talk more about this huh dinner at
your place just the two of us sounds
great cherry grape reline he's dead just
a little bit my question is why doesn't
he fall down he's just dead Aleta he
dies and the only effect is that his
head drops to the side but he just drops
his groceries yeah he doesn't look at
him he's standing right there right now
but he's dead he's completely dead his
knees are locked like a horse's yeah
that's my guess yeah I don't know exact
unless he's acting and it's just a
sketch and then he's just pretending all
right
having food grammars
he's just having tremors that's what
happens when you die the body goes into
small tremors when you died especially
if you die standing right certain
muscles twitch will happen to my great
great grandfather we all talked about it
to this day we'll take a break when we
come back when we come back I got all
the time in the world I really don't
care we come back Josh Hutchinson's here
stick around
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you